your spin-off power book four
force already has fans in a frenzy
we actually um have a clip here that i
would love to show
you know you look like you've already
had a day
and it's only 11 a.m
how you know that
i'm a bartender reading people's part of
my job
some days you just need a whiskey before
me
i hear that
what makes joseph decora the perfect
tommy egan and i hear people almost call
him tommy more than joseph because he's
so inextricably linked to his character
he just was so good like what you all
talking about me yesterday
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming here i was
saying to curtis like people want to
call you
your character's name because you are so
inextricably linked how does that feel
you know i wear it as a badge of honor
i'm so grateful for that i mean i think
that that just means that the fans are
saying you know we it's when you get
claimed by your fans and they're like
you belong to us 50 did it did me right
though because after season two he said
don't worry joe it's gonna be ten years
from now and then and people are gonna
say you know uh uh when you get your
oscar and he's gonna say you know the
one where tommy plays the doctor
what would it be a dream role other than
obviously like a jason uh jason bourne
uh like james bond style thing you have
to look you can so rock that are you
kidding me i'm ready i'm ready put me in
put me in
i mean i say do it
i'm up for it i'm working on the second
iconic role well thanks to curtis the
sky's the limit i'm so happy for this
success i mean i think that really
speaks volumes to 50 as a boss because i
i asked 50 once i said why you always
pass the ball to us people are coming
for 50 cent he said because i'm not
afraid of talent
and that's that's big and he also i say
he said see joe as a boss you have two
options you can either
push people down so so you make sure
that you stay in this position or you
can lift everybody up because you go up
with them yeah when i was an extra never
been kissed i didn't think i'd be
sitting here on your tv you were not i
was no you were not yeah when you were
at navy pier yeah oh my god in chicago
i'm so happy to work with you again
oh my god i have my personal life was
such a mess at that moment
my boyfriend and i like just broke up at
the time and i remember just walking
around chicago and that scene just
crying all the time you see that you had
a shot you missed it
when you find out years later you missed
the shot
oh man
i really my god
i remember you walking past me in the
halls right by where all the uh you know
the rides were and everything you were
on the ferris wheel yeah exactly when
the extra holding was just down the hall
and you and you walked by i was like oh
my god oh my god well
how ironic i was just recently dumped so
you never know somebody's looking at you
someone's like no now um i wanted to ask
you guys because i'm getting super bowl
fever and i'm super excited um but the
super bowl this year has dr dre
eminem mary j blige snoop kendrick lamar
um
are you guys excited i am i'm excited to
see the show because it's going to be
that's probably the best lineup i've
seen for a super bowl halftime it's like
33 of them have been on power shows
well the last time curtis was here
actually we made a video for eminem and
sent it to him
and i was wondering if maybe we could
keep the tradition alive and the three
of us could send a video to him today
okay perfect
um i also got in honor of um eminem i
got
uh
mom's spaghetti yeah
ready you guys ready to make a video for
eminem as tradition
oh oh hi
it's us again
um
i'm just cooking it here
and we're eating some mom's spaghetti
um here i'm here oh drew bryant marshall
i'm eating spaghetti on dry marshall
um and it's me i'm drew you remember me
from the last video i'll remind you you
owe me big time
then i'm joseph socorro i'm his second
favorite white boy
and we
any excuse to eat carbohydrates right
isn't this amazing it's amazing i can't
stop eating i said any excuse to eat
carbs i'm in i'm i'm obsessed i oh so i
got to push the boss over now i'm
getting nervous
thank you joseph sakura thank you for
stopping by and um 50
i just love you i want to keep hanging
out i want to keep playing games and
having fun everybody catch the premiere
of power book for force on stars
starting february 6. we're all here for
it thank you guys so much thank you
we'll be right back
[Music]